welcome to the presentation on quadratic
inequalities
before we get to quadratic inequalities
let's just um
well let's just start graphing some
functions and interpret them and then
we'll slowly move to the inequalities
let's say i had
f of x
is equal to
x squared
plus x
minus 6.
well if we wanted to figure out where
this function intersects the x-axis or
the roots of it we we learned in our
factoring quadratics that we could just
set f of x is equal to zero right
because f of x equals zero when you're
intersecting the x-axis so you would say
x squared
plus x minus six is equal to zero
and you just factor this quadratic
x
plus three
times x minus two equals
and you would learn that the the roots
of this quadratic equation
of this quadratic function
are x is equal to minus 3
and x is equal to 2.
now let's how would how would we uh
visualize this well let's draw this
quadratic function
those are my very uneven lines
so the roots are x is equal to negative
three so this is right here x is in that
minus three
y zero by definition you know one of the
roots is where
f of x is equal to zero so
the y or the f of x axis here is zero
the coordinate is zero and this point
here is
two comma zero
once again this is the x axis
and this is the f of x axis
and we also know that the y-intercept is
minus 6. this isn't the vertex is the
y-intercept that the graph is going to
look
something like this
not as bumpy as what i'm drawing which i
think you get the general idea if you've
ever seen a clean parabola
it looks like that
with
x minus 3 here and x is 2 here
pretty straightforward we figured out
the roots we figured out what it looks
like
now what if we instead of wanting to
know where f x is equal to zero which is
these two points what if we wanted to
know where f of x
is greater than zero what x values make
f of x greater than zero or another way
of saying it what x values make this
statement true
x squared plus x
minus six
is greater than zero right this is just
f of x
well if we look at the graph when is f
of x greater than zero well this is the
f of x axis and when are we in positive
territory well f x is greater than zero
here let me draw that in another color
is greater than zero here
right because it's above
the x-axis and f of x is greater than 0
here
so just visually looking at it
what x
values make this true
well this is true whenever x is
less than minus 3
right or whenever x is greater than 2
right because when x is greater than 2
f of x
is greater than 0 and when x is less
than negative three
f of x is greater than zero so we would
say the solution to this quadratic
inequality and we pretty much solve this
visually
is
x
is less than minus three
or
x
is greater than two and you could test
it out you could try out the number uh
minus four and you should get f of x
being greater than zero you could try it
out here
or you could try out the number 3 and
make sure that this works and you can
just make sure that you could for
example try out the number 0 and make
sure that 0 doesn't work right because 0
is between the 2 roots it actually turns
out that when x is equal to zero f of x
is minus six which is definitely less
than zero
so i think this will give you a visual
intuition of what this quadratic
inequality means and now with that
visual intuition in the back of your
mind let's do some more problems and
maybe we won't have to go through the
exercise of drawing it but but maybe i
will draw it just to
make sure that the point hits home
let me give you a slightly trickier
problem let's see i had minus
x squared
whoops minus x squared
minus
3x
plus 28.
let me say is greater than zero
well i want to get rid of this negative
sign in front of the x squared i just
don't like it there because it makes it
look more confusing to factor so i'm
going to multiply everything by negative
1
both sides i get x squared
plus 3x
minus 28
and when you multiply or divide by a
negative with any inequality you have to
swap the sign
so this is now going to be less than 0
all right
and if we were to factor this we get
x
plus
7
times
x minus four
is less than zero
so this was equal to zero we would know
that the two roots of this function
let's say that let's define the function
f of x let's define the function as f of
x is equal to well we could define it as
this or this because it's the same thing
but let's just for simplicity let's
define it as x plus 7
times x minus 4. that's f of x right
well after factoring it we know that the
roots of this
the roots are
x is equal to minus seven
excuse me my throat is dry i just ate
too many almonds
and x is equal to four
now what we want to know is what x
values make this inequality true
if this was inequality we'd be done
we want to know what makes this
inequality true and i'll give you a
little bit of a trick
it's always going to be the numbers in
between the two roots or outside of the
two roots
so what i do whenever i'm doing this
quick on a test or something i just test
numbers that are either between the
roots or outside of the two roots
so let's pick a number that's between
x equals minus seven and x equals four
well let's try
try
x equals zero
well f of zero
is equal to we could do it right here f
of zero is zero plus seven
whoops
times zero minus four
is just seven
times minus four
which is minus twenty eight
so f of zero is minus 28.
now
is this this is what this is the
function we're working with is this less
than 0
well yeah it is
so it actually turns out that a number
an x value between the two roots works
so actually i immediately know that the
answer here is all of the x's that are
between the two roots so we could say
that the solution to this
is
minus 7
is less than x
which is less than 4.
you could have done it the other way you
could have tried a number that's
outside of the roots either
less than minus 7 or greater than 4 and
have tried it out let's say if you had
tried out 5
try x equals 5.
well then f of 5
would be
12
12
times 1 right which is equal to 12.
f of 5 is 12. is that less than 0
no so that wouldn't have worked so once
again that gives us a confidence that we
got the right interval and if we wanted
to think about this
visually
right because we've got this answer
when you do it visually it actually
makes i think
a lot of sense but maybe
i'm biased let me erase this real fast
if you look at it visually it looks like
this
oh whoop that's way too fat
let me do it on the skinnier pen
if you draw it visually
and this is the parabola right this is f
of x
the roots here are minus
we're saying that for all x values
between these two numbers
f of x is less than zero and that looks
that makes sense because when is f of x
less than zero well this is
this is the graph of f of x right
this is f of x
and what is f of x less than 0 right
here so what x values give us that well
the x values that give us that
are right here i hope i'm not confusing
you too much with these visual graphs
and and you're probably saying well how
do i know i don't include 0s well you
could try it out but if you uh how come
i don't include the roots well at the
roots f of x is equal to 0. so if this
was this if this was less than or equal
to 0 then the answer
would be
negative 7 is less than or equal to x is
less than or equal to 4.
i hope that gives you a sense you pretty
much just have to try a number in
between the roots and try a number
outside of the roots and that tells you
what interval will make the inequality
true
i'll see you in the next presentation